sometimes I just buy food and put in the
fridge and just wait for it to be left
over
right off the bat this hot ones really
good something about that cheese is real
good when it's hot she's never gonna be
as like gooey and delicious as it
originally was so I like pros oh man
that's amazing just like I said I'm
microwaved it this is like something
that people like almost more there's
just something so like heartwarming
about leftover cold pizza doesn't move
which is always good okay yeah all right
the whole different experience like
sometimes if we're just feeling lazy you
just want to open the fridge and get
something but this is so much more
satisfying I still like the cold one
better
I just went better to me a little more
flavorful cold that's so weird
we getting spaghetti spaghetti yeah it
is always better a day later I don't
know why put a little parmesan on it
damn you got yourself another meal
that's cold spaghetti that's not a thing
I hands down eco spaghetti I hate this
whoa I think there's maybe a texture
slimy thing happening it's too cold I'm
okay with it I don't like it
well cuz it's cold spaghetti you can't
skimp on the microwave on this one no
I'll eat your yeah go boil
shrimp pad thai hot leftover ties to
familiar friend okay good that's really
great the microwaves actually helps us
feel like I might be getting a little
more flavor on the cold it's kind of
just dance there's a civil war happening
in your mouth not bad not bad if I have
the opportunity to go two feet to my
left and put in the microwave I'm
definitely gonna take that if I had this
already the night before I might want to
switch it up and have cold the next day
you can't eat Thai food cold like he
told y'all that my mom told me your
mom's wrong vegetable lo mein yes is
good is it like college to heat it up
ones just like dry they kind of just
like Latin now and you're like there's
no way doesn't compete with this I see
though I think we're gonna get into some
territory where the cold doesn't fly the
cold one looks sloppy
whoa I think the cold is here make it
sweeter I actually think I was way wrong
it's totally fine that's great
well my windy one cold is awesome this
one's about earn comes hot but I see the
appeal for this one Jim clapping people
eat Thanksgiving leftovers for weeks
yeah this is the Star Wars have
leftovers that's delicious I love
Thanksgiving so much why would you
dishonor it by not me eat again turkey
looks daunting it's not good old mashed
potatoes totally fine are you kidding me
what is this this is like a dirt clod
this tastes bad kind of take me to bland
Ville USA population none do whatever
you gotta do to eat the damn thing you
know people there's hungry people
everywhere we're in a very privileged
position to be sitting here arguing
about the temperature of my leftover
food that I couldn't finish if you're
gonna recog it in a microwave we don't
capture the essence of the original meal
that was left over for you to eat magic
makes sense it makes all the sense it
does that